okay [ __ ] your boss like a rebel I
think it's kind of a little late at
night mana right now plan I want
actually not that light with the fact my
side anyway we're gonna play this new
game called the kingdom of loathing and
it's apparently an RPG a comic Oh free
is like not text-based like cheap based
I guess I don't know apparently it's
great though so here it is tick whatever
and you could be a person in a danger
okay so let's do it's create a character
okay and I will be excels muscles the
kid success relies on mystical noodle
crap no no I would someone kind of
strong mystical now do you killer T of
thee now I need I need to see I'll
clobber
okay BAM a his name is mister wreck
now shut okay mr. Rick is taken club a
wreck hey gob ma let's do this
okay play okay here we go
set up a threat thank you
they came to a loathing okay till it's
on the right okay my guy muscle three my
c1 moxie there know how okay her request
is it's a tool Oriole at on Mont knew in
the big mountains okay here we go how I
go holy [ __ ] tutorial ok Mountain ooh
okay there is the tada Rio the blood
speaks to me as I project a Wacka Wacka
make sure the ropes and I teaching my
inventory
click on this in the menu that's up
there okay [ __ ] wasn't it more show
supposed to learn oh I got a completed I
guess Saget lunch okay okay
Oh equipped the item totally [ __ ] yes I
clipped and equipped okay good good and
you got back what is this grimace Ronald
do logout down okay
money went out to patreon adventuring
the area cost one adventurer we're
headed your adventure points okay
you're fighting a create a tacit okay
and for damage you attack it when the
fight get to be possible sticks to
strongest one sarcasm okay
pack them out now just two more crazy
okay attack God got answer again okay
let's all good good can I just keep on
the veteran you getting a lot of [ __ ]
almost is going up
why can I just keep on doing this how do
I not like one out of adventure points
where's my adventure points
yeah I think I have online with it
that's weird
okay well how HP is not at 12 I could
actually [ __ ] die [ __ ] let me just
do this a couple times a lemon how am I
not like dying
okay maybe eat some [ __ ]
meat adventures remaining muscularity
points loading description
okay I guess I'll equip this habit okay
anyway let me just get back to this
thing here we go here we go Mountain oh
the tutorial take aim at some scales
mimei mmm still clogging frenzy what is
this do a sell clothing would all right
great clobber no thank you okay mister
to Dario okay hit down new squad run
through an amis use clobber okay here we
go
here we go how [ __ ]
ranchera again yeah I got that bag here
I go [ __ ] my guys [ __ ] dying okay
back to the tote mass tag
now meets currency okay campsite I get
this tent okay um okay that's at the
camp round wrestling your time
oh my god baby wow that's great
okay go - okay certificate of there we
go
teach my cooking I look at it cook
install it in my campsite okay yes
oh shut suck at kickball ever
hmm lemon
okay lemon popsicle Elliot Elliot is
loud popsicle there you go I can't - it
matches okay I feel oh I'd be a little
boring it's kind of just a learning but
yet cocktails good crafting make a
cocktail chinned wits 11 let's get our
bed a whole whisking sound like okay I
need this there we go okay here we go
back to the smelt no to that tote we're
ready okay let's do this - say side tap
the [ __ ] is this Palin managed got a
loan in clever trick a little too
powered and then you can help - what
mistakes parts okay so these are the
east of good places
okay class is guilt okay I head over to
the Brotherhood of SmackDown on the
right side of the tracks
okay where's the right side there I go
and I was go there hello got there and I
proved yourself okay
sauce is measure yes particular and find
the biggest hot you get defeat into it
to card bring back the sauce different
measurement now I've got with new broad
Plains okay let's go attack yeah I got
uh I need to eat something cut out [ __ ]
clobber him okay got clobber him again
now firecracker
barbecue team what kill him get good
good [ __ ] I need Oh grab the sausage
center speaking mean literally we got
big sausage here like I bet this isn't
that big like measured at centimeter
something so it seems bigger that shows
you what no it's pretty huge now why
does it like hurt my buddy now is that
fun okay you char just looking at it
grab that sausage 11-inch it's got to be
a bigger soldiers than that
CLOB him okay there's got to be a bigger
sausage cooking high-ranking officer
the [ __ ] okay
can I can see what's going on here okay
I'll make a password to make it faster
and see okay popping [ __ ]
I need a bigger sausage we want to knob
so I got a rod I feel like this could be
a bigger sausage here no well I'll help
them lunch another quest
well [ __ ] okay anyways Larry back is
this thing - this guy right set of
tracks brother that's Mac down here
sorry I have your sausage now we're in
this [ __ ] okay talk to torque the
trainer smack it to your gets provisions
I like some from a fight by bad [ __ ]
I need like a weapon
hella tark oh [ __ ] there's some strong
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] here okay anyway I buy
some pumpkin tongue hear from dr. onyx
Medicine Show and it can able to see
here there we go I'll buy this then
again
okay where we go bring up half-assed
regeneration what's up [ __ ] is this
dough where is it what is it that sort
of let's lock that [ __ ]
okay I got to bike it out what that's
why though with a price tag on it
okay we've got the council blowing
what's that again council of lowly
council of loathing here we go we need
mosquito larvae don't ask why because we
will tell you and then again is the best
place to find mosquito larvae is the
spooky forest which isn't a distant one
okay okay I'll walk man
can I just [ __ ] Club them betcha
again clop this bench oh [ __ ] Club and I
get [ __ ] Club it again Club it again
there we go
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is tough
two points of damage one point of damage
okay I want I need the [ __ ] heal dude
a campground can't go rest in my tap
thank you yeah I got it baby
okay let's go back [ __ ] bear claw
Bram copper him to damage to damage yeah
kill them
holy [ __ ] how come this one is I'll let
the damage okay this is tricky the armor
real respite okay move this down so you
guys can see a little better
there's nothing really there okay here
we go okay you managed to quite get
quite a ways to the forest without
running into one point
[ __ ] your monster is caught my breath
okay it says three pads maybe I look for
ski to the council once I lay eggs and
the water did and explore the string
and actually give the marsh okay we got
it baby
I got it I got it
say side town now shut down here fine
was a meet holy [ __ ] buy it to market
square
where's the general start where the
Heron has that menu now 500
it kind of spend it I need [ __ ]
weapons
install touring what does that do
okay mosquito larvae where is it put
terrarium well yes he's cute half a day
yeah now what is a good one
put them in the charring we're now given
with you their experience Jericho
okay this is good okay uh distant woods
word okay
talk the owner a typical tavern where is
it
specialist tavern I guess this guy I had
a I'm barred bartender
nice to meet you Bart and here's a rat
problem there Reitsma sellers I can't
let me tell these [ __ ] explore the
darkness attack this [ __ ] hey Dad
for damage of blood and then Jackson a
deal holy [ __ ]
I can't eight hit points attack and a
perfect
i smilin rat it's kind of yeah okay
tell this [ __ ] hey Dad
oh [ __ ] I went the [ __ ] die kill it
I'm [ __ ] dead I'm [ __ ] I did
Banna that's right okay so let me see 40
per day
okay anyway um fought for website Oh
kill these guys
okay my my better scary wha damage right
now I don't want to pay it here run away
alright
there we go oh [ __ ] just [ __ ] wasted
some help the corpse of men Tourette's
[ __ ] up look at them feed by the rats
you steal clever that's so sad
okay handle the bomb and the shiny ring
you see what that does
no I'll keep her in there okay the
helmet I got this scimitar to the three
now the club that just put down
power 10 that way one or two okay good
um
fucking-a here we go
wait now wasn't there something lousy
glowing where was it
can't what does it do now
give you three adventures yeah [ __ ] it
there we go
attack this batch haste that attack this
batch
thanks dad attack testbench oh [ __ ] so
hot
okay two cc's of blood [ __ ] I need
[ __ ] out die
fine help but I never next egg holy [ __ ]
you give me a [ __ ] lot egg
usable what the [ __ ] is that there is no
shine I already do that okay I will
don't die but [ __ ] it turn it off hell
up Bart we fixed your problem
three flagons of typical taverns well
thank you holy [ __ ] Lohan is going in
here that's fantastic it's a
suspicious-looking guy
well it's surely drugs that guy's [ __ ]
drugged up nope
[ __ ] I'll do it
see what does though
and I use it when I need it like really
badly one day okay let me have my
[ __ ] now if you'll attack you you may
attack this [ __ ] check them again
attack them again [ __ ] I scold sir
slits Oh what do you kids a pound old
[ __ ] how do I check on rhodius done it
no thank you wait what happens I done it
and I was a morally [ __ ] people I'm not
[ __ ] around in this game okay
my son has options crapping your scales
okay and we got to figure out what's
something to do here some woods the
forest village
how much mean I got the bounty hunters
okay
hang down oh [ __ ] bounty-hunting comment
power a hundred moxie and it must use
for well [ __ ] okay well let me get this
one collect eight blood strange Procrit
some nog olive BBQ items where Eliza
nearby clients ok venture again attack
one of eight so far I just got to watch
my each be really kiss the chef
kisum you holy [ __ ]
gonna write down on it can I sell some
[ __ ]
plot a cunning list game I got two of
eight that guy's got to see guns take on
two of eight still [ __ ] doctor huh blows
mouth on your way to Cobbs for the cold
and it will ship playing apparition
appears and recites of strange and get
pwned gives me a map twit I need to keep
on killing these [ __ ] serve your
sentence not [ __ ] our eyes and we're
involved attack attack okay let me just
keep on gun damage 308 I want to reduce
watch my HP four of eight I got the
lunch box plastic chairs chest
I see a doctor
my god is pretty good shapes are up kick
the chef attack him
okay bad way we aren't doing God what
Kelly's [ __ ] cops they're killing
these cops
come on need one more cop 1 more cop
inch 1/8 another cop 7 of 8 7 of 8
give me that cop
gimme that cop where is our vote
my HP is going up and I like dirty I
wrote looks like [ __ ] 10
okay good good
I need to go the bounty on Murr [ __ ]
kill this [ __ ] real quick hello Diaz
house they down real quick
forty five kills we [ __ ] okay anyway um
[ __ ] I think it wasn't the forest
yeah I have a filthy Lucar
[ __ ] is that - coin
okay it's dirty because it got passed
down a lot disgusting okay well maybe
only one now I need something good
what's a pump - a puppy holy [ __ ] I'd
like a poppy - familiar
what the [ __ ] is this one the nose one
usable
how do I get this one
no thank you that is disgusting okay
let me get these ones okay go to mount
make large huge till I have the mount
mclarge huge [ __ ] of that now I make
large huge nearby Plains nope campground
no ketchup now thank you very once nope
how do i this guy tell you where mount
McClarty is orcish snowboarders 13 I
feel like it's in the big mountains
what the [ __ ] is this a mimic [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] debt no so live
okay my colossal closet
where'd I get another task you would
slay the boss bat he's in the bat whole
new airplanes okay the bad hall oh [ __ ]
block block block wanna junction
entryway attack this bench
attack - bench attack come on baby
just keep on attacking
and again we got a guano Junction I have
the stuff protection
it's the where is it
just [ __ ] hat it back while I was
that do I thought I just had a good
smelling thing where is it consumables
equipment there it is
why can't I equip this Hyundai 10
basement Stockley points
[ __ ] what do I have 5 and I [ __ ]
increase that
copier so motto is [ __ ] I got some good
[ __ ] now title on it
chef's hat dirty not bad back ok um she
really sell the [ __ ]
we're afraid I'm gonna like loose [ __ ]
oh okay now because the mop is not here
holy [ __ ] I got a lot of [ __ ] meat
okay I gotta figure I gotta get trained
real quick seaside town
all right side of the tracks I think
it's the Brotherhood or I can learn the
missed ISM friends little rain not only
interested in that down smack a Toria
turtle taming supplies sale library
enchanted brass knuckles ten
line up clock how do I [ __ ] this is
interesting
this is a pretty interesting now thank
you not noob star wet touch
and I [ __ ] alright
her oh I need a hermit permit required
weird dungeon ears association now I
need to get like training dude okay
oh [ __ ] I need a [ __ ] again 20 now in
the fight I get close with Cola
this is Dale did you mean it
[ __ ] weird powerful what the [ __ ] is
that okay uh maybe there's some way I
can just [ __ ] in how do I get my oh my
mystic at seven oh [ __ ]
wait what's Hannah what's in that tribal
place we can do some [ __ ] for me the
crap at mystic shed there we go yes tell
me more
okay cocky God okay here we go
continuum transfunctioner
okay here we go let's see what happens
okay so I put it on
what the [ __ ] to this yet
okay well it's gonna do Shep Takei is
actually crazy
oh shut
[ __ ] 10 you can get off pixely if you
get a pixel
okay the signs tent
holy [ __ ] this guy's tough stuff like
that run away
okay I got to go back to this [ __ ]
hole see if I could do something
so I just keep on fighting until I get
mysticism at seven
okay get my stuff okay here we go we got
keep doing it one of the ten I'm a date
right now can I thirty two thirty I got
bad cut let's back up to keep forgetting
I'm like in the middle of the [ __ ]
thing let's back up do where is it where
is it where is it so you can crap [ __ ]
with it but I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is
oh great mm-hm-hm-hm-hm attack but yes i
attack [ __ ] I might do it there good now
okay muscle pulling it what he's got a
pound
come on dad come on bro come on bro
get made up get that mr. as I'm up for
moving get that mr. sum up for me about
9:00 okay [ __ ]
I almost had 10 almost at 10:00
[ __ ] don't die [ __ ] I died
come on [ __ ] come on [ __ ]
get me a ten get level enough a love on
up
anything I could [ __ ] take
it's a [ __ ] mess ism
what o'clock a cola
tipnis three I've got [ __ ] okay I guess
I had to [ __ ] fight it
let's go come on back come on back
almost shut
what does moxie do what was that a
[ __ ] stamina for today almost come on
yeah okay I'm good the [ __ ] mr. Colley's
tat ya little [ __ ] yeah little [ __ ]
I do not want to use up all my [ __ ]
stamina on that don't [ __ ] is there
Sina pass could be the wall sleazy back
alley
I'm at train line [ __ ] spider I need
to [ __ ] I need to buy [ __ ] Market
Square here we go
the flea market the armored s what I
[ __ ] need muscle requires 60 holy [ __ ]
45
I have 20 20
Sarah for Jane okay
okay Hartley we clip this [ __ ] equipment
and then this is just a law what one
okay I got to go to the right side of
the tracks
where's the bike right here and I got to
fight this [ __ ] black Jews what the
[ __ ] it took a Crisanta pee it holy [ __ ]
and I killed my guy a crepe it's just a
dope a face with dealt with face in it
the gingerbread burger oh my god and
again this is [ __ ] up a glove with
enchanted icing Oh a dinner troll oh no
anything okay and with the heart of
madness strange colors office bagel mat
5000 this as popular be on machines is
so shelf strong people title with all
dressed different books
insert a lot of dough I got the replan
bagels
part missing take your recipe books cook
through water good with soda water you
get low for soda bread
interesting oh [ __ ] - [ __ ] am i doing
why am I here the keyhole keeps licking
your palm it tickles do I have I thought
I had like a lot of ring lawd glove
wench anti-icing for those it's creamy
its ass weird
[Music]
get through the door you have to keep
fighting
I get lady try open the door again you
need to focus
time to die break brother
open the damn door okay here we go the
cake Lord holy [ __ ] I won the fight it's
Madeline hey MA
get her rescue me by throwing all my
stock oh she's pissed off so [ __ ] I was
drugged
market square okay anyways I got to go
back to this guy popular park
mock's your card is 25
yeah I'll take these pants Fady
equipment creepy mask we shift put the
[ __ ]
Roxie's tent all [ __ ] night
Jesus okay I guess I got to get to the
let me use that Papua machine I have the
part pop-tart okay I only have 31 so I
guess I'll [ __ ] use it to take on
this bat well I'll keep doing until I
get my mentality to ten and this would
probably at the end for today then right
right let me sing sing
[ __ ] strong now you know here we go
here we go step stanch damage I'm almost
at nine
anybody's the rate of team oh [ __ ] okay
let's get inebriated okay manipulate
okay let me just let me eat these these
chairs see the faster way to eat all
this [ __ ]
up too full to eat that can I drink gin
they're not falling down to rock yeah if
I get
holy [ __ ] okay guys I [ __ ] up
stores heals a lot
feels a bit okay I gotta pick up some
flowers the wrong side of the tracks
okay let's trunk it's to Purdue
okay horrible idea okay [ __ ] what I have
to go over goal mock
well you could tell the University oh my
god a drunk free card
okay so I'm not in a stupor anymore okay
can we go back to fighting I'm almost at
them okay I'm in 11 I just need to get
to 10 miss tality and I get the I can
wear that ring to get rid of smell like
the ring of freshness sure will not air
freshener and then I can take on the
guano come on
how about that I 2827 I'm right on
[ __ ] Sam let's downwards right here
if you go missed it come on come on
[ __ ] come on come up [ __ ] come on
[ __ ] come up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] up babe a club Iraq bad I almost
almost come on okay almost at 10
mythicality
[ __ ]
there we go it's at 10:00 okay that
whole clap Matt can I only wear one at
time right
I'm gonna let me wear
okay bad hundreds [ __ ] Africa the guano
junction here we go see what we can do
we only have 13 points left
I got spooky damage the [ __ ] they got
ten left sonar in a biscuit that do
sonar in a biscuit if you miss Glenny
send lot of tow freaks bats out well I
only have nine health left so I really
want to do that right now
we got a wad of dough eight seven six
five
what's going on here a scream bat you
win the fight crumbling so thing broke
okay here we go
the batter at five four three two one
okay okay I'm out of stamina for today
well anyways wait
remember I can eat some more connait
some are too full to eat that okay I
guess I'll just get my guy [ __ ] drunk
okay well anyways that's it for today
thanks for watching and we'll continue
this mission tomorrow I guess die nice
thank you thank you